I came to this video playing Joss a
sunday again I had just played him in
this b 3 opening just try something else
maybe this is a [ __ ] ganna have I
account this I am always playing playing
and wouldn't be three ok so we transpose
them into a into a ratty opening the
line both that I have played a number of
times as black so he's trying to get in
Queen to a one okay I'll do this the
space gain I'm always debatable if this
is good but I think black should should
take the space if I if possible
check yeah that's always tricky I
normally play it differently with Roxy
to win so I'm not not with the Queen a
one rookie 20 west fact that this is
this is a bit down a bit strange in the
long run okay if I go here and intending
you five what is he doing against this
nothing he's doing nothing against the
t5 maybe they couldn't do anything but
what do I isn't f2 just exploding here
what what am I missing
hmm
the issue is in addition i meanwe secret
putting the nite nite c2 I take F 2 and
c2 it's not only breaking through on f2
but also just using this piece on c2
yeah and yeah here i can take it if you
can take here winning a pizza yeah okay
at least the remaining pieces the
Bishop's are ok now but I have I have 11
more
okay maybe i can i can check enter here
quickly and look see one it's not clear
that this is really leading to much when
I should have thought a moment about
this now now be five is hanging but i
can look clay rook seawall and rugby one
actually using this tempo and then go
work to be one saving the beep on and
this is this manner okay replace quincy
to probably and now i need to move the
bishop quincy adis it's a bit bit of a
problem probably I mean I g4 I can just
take with the bishop hg queen age 4 and
wins I guess check
gee 494 a stronger actually if he plays
it g4
hmm not sure this is not threatening
much I think
I don't don't really see a direct win
here
I'm ID actually is Queen g600 and
crouppen and no move the night then I
kingi 695 elders would be them will be
nice okay so can I not take it too now
is this is this not not on okay maybe
Bishop f6 now as a threat
hmm
yeah maybe okay let's do this ahead plan
to move fish I plan to move before hand
okay I don't really see the threaten
maybe maybe I'm overlooking i just think
i can take it to what is the the big
point okay let's grab it
roop ghs so maybe the threat time
morning maybe this is the threat term
unbelievable what I'm doing here we
should be forced my idea group g7 Bishop
before rook g5 check King e6
I don't see how I don't see made at the
moment check my notes are excellent
defenders iam
rookie 59 if i I don't I don't see a
mate really don't maybe maybe find some
check the picture or something check
check yeah this this is a possibility
Bishop check
check that's it oh no check white
resigns wow I really dare really didn't
need to do this kind of stunt with my
king it is it seems to be winning all
the time but it you know it is totally
winning all the time but I had to I had
my doubts check check check check Mike
ef5 was even was even general but a chat
it is a window who ya made it turn a bit
but more difficult than the necessary i
guess night h5 year I was I was thinking
that Queen c8 is a bit annoying i should
get the age 7 square so I played Bishop
f5 but you just need to calculate a bit
here this is threatening and made you
must play that check and this is getting
very ugly yeah that's the far the
easiest way to win ok but I'm glad I won
this at all thanks for watching